so I recently made an episode of Horror
history on Grimace and there's a lot of
stuff that didn't make the cut that I
wanted to share primarily there's a lot
of weird Grimace merchandise that I
found online I think this is like one of
those temporary tattoo things if I'm not
mistaken I always just find it strange
and kind of creepy whenever they draw
Grimace so poorly like this and there's
another example here this is like a
Grimace bead game I've mentioned this in
the video but it reminds me of like this
meme of Carl Weezer where he's just
drawn very badly so this is a Grimace
pencil sharpener and I think it's kind
of creepy on its own like the eyes the
mouth like the positioning of the hands
it's kind of just a creepy image and
then you think about the fact that it's
a pencil sharpener and it's like where
does the pencil go we kind of know where
the pencil goes I found another picture
of it it's not as bad as we thought okay
it's not as bad as we thought this is
like the creepiest Grimace merchandise
thing that I think I found like the fact
that it's orange is kind of off-putting
but then when you look at the eyes they
just look so Hollow and I I don't know
what this thing is it's just like an
orange Grimace figure that they made for
some reason there is other stuff that we
found so let me know if you want to see
more